and i still have people coming up to me
today saying are you the real team torbs
and they remember that sketch on
saturday night live
and your host
[Applause]
this saturday tesla ceo elon musk will
host saturday night live
the legendary show is typically led each
week by movie stars musicians and
athletes
and musk is one of only a handful of
business leaders to host the show
so we thought we'd ask another member of
this small group to recount his
experience
in hopes it might give elon some nuggets
of wisdom
the hosting came about because i was
asked by
lorne michaels i'd run for president on
an unusual platform
getting rid of the tax code the flat tax
uh didn't succeed but
roiled the political water so they
thought it would be a hoot to have me on
saturday night live
people who'd worked with me politically
thought it was a very dangerous thing to
do
we got reassurances from lorne michaels
that they wouldn't be doing anything
that i wouldn't
like or at least have fun with and
my five daughters who really run the
show
said you must do it so i said yes before
saturday night live could retract the
invitation
well i ended up going to bp module
against for a couple of jello shots
so what advice does steve have for elon
before his big day
don't be bashful about some sketches
that may poke a little fun at you
as long as it's not nasty or cruel uh
people like it when you can
take a little pot shot at yourself or be
the
target in a good good natured way so
keep the thing upbeat good natured have
fun at it
and recognize it's a once-in-a-lifetime
opportunity
keep your day job as i did because it
does not lead to
big contracts or movie producers banging
at your door
hosting snl is a big deal so we wanted
to know
what were some of the things the forbes
editor-in-chief remembered most from
that week
one of the other nice surprises is that
you
get paid you have temporarily joined the
union and
if you have a speaking part royalties
are sliding scale
well ted i'm flattered by your
suggestion
but i didn't write the book literally
sliding
last year i think uh my net royalty
from the show was two dollars and
sixteen cents
i think the gross was five dollars
before deductions
steve also had a surprising answer for
one of the most memorable people from
the show
the cue card holder i did write a note
to uh the guy who
did that job you have to be at the right
angle for all the actors
right time to make it work so you don't
stumble thinks it goes seamlessly i
wrote him a thank you note
and he said years later i was the only
one who ever thanked him
and i i thought that was strange without
him
would there be no show for crying out
loud
he was essential